a pause in reign a chance to survey the
disaster that has unfolded in pakistan
two months into the monsoon season the
country has declared a national
emergency
pakistani leaders including the prime
minister himself seeing the floods up
close
promising to mobilize more aid but the
skies have dumped so much water no
amount of help seems like enough
driving through the waterlogged interior
of sindh province you'd be hard-pressed
to spot a single rescue crew
but death and destruction abound
who will save us when will the waters
recede what happens now
people in flood streak in pakistan left
with questions
but little else
no one comes here not the landlords no
one from the government no one comes to
us everyone is just lying here starving
children little ones the poor don't have
anything where should we go back to our
village it's not even there anymore
our house is sank in the water we're
dying from hunger we have nothing
everything is gone and we've become
beggars we're starving we're starving
everywhere in sindh
desperate testimonies and pleas for help
for the moment the human suffering the
devastation of people's lands and their
homes it is worst here in sindh province
but just in the last few days the
flooding from melting glaciers and
rainfall in the north of the country has
gotten so bad that even though it is
quite difficult to imagine what is
happening in the north of the country
could overtake what is happening here
flood water cascading through the swath
valley in hyber pakhtun hua province
is moving swiftly south
cutting down anything in its path
downstream flash flood warnings and
evacuation orders are in effect
volunteers pulling the dead from the
water are warning people to stay away
from the rivers levels are rising faster
than expected
it is time they say
to get to higher ground
zain basravi al-jazeera dadu district in
pakistan province